Voiceover:Which of the following
can represent a vector?
A vector is something that
has both a magnitude and a direction.
Let's see which one of these
could represent something
that has a magnitude and a direction.
The first choice right
over here is the number 5.
5 could represent a magnitude,
you could say, essentially,
how large something is.
That's all the information has.
It doesn't say 5 in a certain direction.
This one by itself would not be a
or it couldn't represent a vector.
You need to specify a direction as well.
The angle measure 5 degrees.
Well the angle measure 5 degrees
could represent a direction.
If you say it's 5 degrees.
Let's say that's the positive X axis
that's the positive Y axis.
If you said it's 5 degrees relative
to the positive X axis.
If you said something like this,
so if you had 5 degrees over there,
that would be specifying a direction,
but it's not giving us a magnitude.
It's not saying how far in that direction
or how large in that direction.
An angle measure of 5 degrees,
you're giving us a direction,
but no magnitude.
Let's just cross these out.
The  point (5,5). Now this is interesting.
If we say that the point is
the end point of a vector
that starts at the origin,
so lets draw that out.
That's the positive X
axis, positive Y axis.
This is 1,2,3,4,5 in the
horizontal direction.
1,2,3,4,5 in the positive
vertical direction.
The .5,5 is going to be right over there.
If you said that this
represents the head of a vector
who's tail is at the origin.
The vector would look something like this.
Now, you're giving both a
magnitude and a direction.
What's the magnitude?
What's the distance between the origin
and this point, right over here.
You could solve using the Pythagorean theorem
and the direction, it's
this general direction.
This could specify a
magnitude and a direction.
This could represent a vector.
The outcome of 5+5,
obviously that's just 10.
That's just a number.
For the same reason, this first choice,
if I just have a number,
that could be a magnitude,
but we don't have a direction as well.
This could not represent and
that one could not represent a vector.